hi I'm fair and cousins sitting in for
David Pakman and this is the david
pakman show thanks for joining us listen
I know a lot of people have been very
anxious recently wondering about the
outcome of the war on poverty after all
this is a war that we have been fighting
as a country since the early 1960s well
I am proud to announce that according to
the Trump administration we have finally
won the war on poverty all our poverty
troops can come home rejoin the families
that they've been missing for decades
because the war on poverty is officially
over and we won poverty lost now
obviously that's not true right we all
know that poverty still exists in a very
big way here in the United States but
that didn't stop this administration
recently from telling the world that we
beat poverty here in the United States
and they did that based on faulty math
from the administration what happened
was that they claimed that since 1961
the poverty rate in the United States
has fallen from 30 percent to 3 percent
now 3 percent poverty would be a
phenomenal measure of in any country
anybody would be happy to only have 3
percent poverty unfortunately again
they're using the wrong map what the
administration did to figure that 3
percent number was that they based their
poverty measure on purchases purchasing
power of American citizens which happens
to include buying things with food
stamps or getting medical care with a
program like Medicaid that's money that
comes from the federal government but
you spent it you spent it therefore you
have greater purchasing power therefore
you are not in poverty reality says that
the poverty rate in the United States is
somewhere between 12 point 7 percent
according to the government and 14
percent according to the US Census
Bureau based on the proper measure of
poverty
we
which is a person's income how much
money they get each month so anywhere
between twelve point seven to fourteen
percent is what the real number is it is
down from what we saw you know during
the Bush administration those numbers
hit almost 18 percent at that time but
it's still a very real problem
so why in god's name would this
administration be telling us that we won
the war on poverty well they actually
answered that question in their own
little announcement about winning the
war it's because they want to cut social
safety net programs so they have to make
it seem like those programs are
unnecessary here in the United States
one of the big drivers of this let's cut
everything in the world that helps the
less fortunate is Paul Ryan and as we
all know Paul Ryan not seeking
re-election he's only got a few more
months in office but it has been a dream
of his since he was a child to cut the
social safety net out of the United
States of America I mean most little
kids go outside they play they pretend
to be superheroes Paul Ryan went outside
and played and I'm assuming practiced
with a pair of scissors pretending he
was cutting that safety net cutting red
tape that was his superpower getting rid
of protections that keep American
citizens alive and that's what he wants
to do here and he's using these faulty
poverty numbers to do it and the
administration right now is enabling him
if you think back a few weeks ago the UN
did a report on what they call extreme
poverty here in the United States those
are people who are living on basically
less than about $4 per day extreme
poverty they estimated that it's about
18 million American citizens living
under those conditions the
administration snapped back at them and
said nope
by our count which we don't let you see
the numbers it's only about 250,000 that
that live under those conditions which
means that it doesn't exist they're
doing the same thing here with just
regular poverty numbers we know it
exists
depending on where you live in this
country it's not that hard to see it is
an everyday reality for millions upon
millions of American citizens take it
from me listen I live in the south we
see it all around us most of us at one
point of our lives or maybe even right
now are in it it's not pleasant it's not
pretty but it is very very real and for
this administration to try to use this
one to lie and say that it's not
happening but to to cut away the safety
net that is absolutely deplorable and I
think that is an apt descriptor for this
deplorable here's the thing Paul Ryan
doesn't think we won the war on poverty
he doesn't think that poverty has gone
away in the United States but he does
still think that because things are
decent in the economy at this very
second we should cut the social safety
nets a couple weeks ago Paul Ryan had
this to say in a speech he said in this
economy with all of the opportunities
available there could not be a better
time to help more people move from
welfare to work so he is out there still
today this week last week on his Twitter
feed telling us that things are so great
that all of you lazy people you can go
find a job because in Republican world
if you're on welfare it is 100% because
you're because you're lazy
not maybe because you had an accident
you're disabled not maybe because the
job you had been working for 25 years
got shipped overseas because companies
wanted to save a few dollars here and
there not maybe because of the trade
wars that are currently costing hundreds
upon hundreds of jobs every week in this
country no you're lazy in Paul Ryan's
eyes and in the eyes of too many
Republican leaders in Washington DC the
social safety net keeps people from
living on the streets and even then
sometimes it can't completely keep
people off that there are work
requirements for
most of these programs but Republicans
would rather go out there and repeat the
lies that they have been telling us
since the 1980s about these alleged
welfare queens the people live in high
on the hog off the government's a dollar
which could not be further from the
truth they would rather lie to you about
that than admit the reality that maybe
this economy is not perfect maybe the
private sector is not helping the
situation by sending jobs over the seas
maybe just maybe the federal government
needs to help these people because if
they had to admit that that would
destroy the entire mythos that they have
created as a political party since again
at least that early 1980s possibly going
as far back as the New Deal when
Republicans obviously didn't think the
government should be offering any of
these programs we have a problem here in
the United States of very extreme
poverty and just because things are
chugging along at the moment with the
economy every credible economist out
there is telling us things are about to
come crashing down what we have is an
economy built out of straw something
that is not sustainable something that
is exceptionally fragile and when you
combine things like rising interest
rates which are happening right now
trade wars which are happening right now
income inequality getting greater which
is happening right now
any one of those things has the
potential to devastate a fragile economy
we have all of them so Paul Ryan can
boast all he wants on Twitter right now
about how great the economy is Trump was
doing it this morning as well but at the
end of the day they know the truth they
know that poverty is real they know that
the economy is fragile and they know
that their policies both Trump and Ryan
those two guys that are pushing for this
their policies are going to be the ones
that bring everything crashing down